when the reality of the pandemic started
setting in last year
museums and other organizations
understood the need to preserve
this moment in history they started
collecting artifacts like ppe
signs showing support for healthcare
heroes and vaccine vials
dr tara narula got a look at their
efforts and tells us why this initiative
is so important good morning tara
good morning adriana the pandemic has
left a mark on each of us
as part of an initiative by made by us
history and civic
organizations and museums are banding
together to collect covid19 libraries
a time capsule of 2020 that includes
the voices of healthcare workers
i'm hoping to not have to go back into
that icu ever again
to be honest over the past year icu
nurse missy chen
has been recording history medicine as i
know it right now
is not working for these patients
detailing lessons learned
from covid19 he's sick he's young
he has no major comorbidities
i found that it was a way for me to
really process what i was seeing what i
was feeling and sort of
get it out there i think it saved me
she's part of a community called the
nocturnists
healthcare workers who come together to
share their stories
experiences and emotions what does it
mean to be able to listen to
other individuals recordings and diaries
it's been very comforting
um and less isolating in a way it's this
sort of shared collective
trauma it's a very powerful thing to
listen to these voices
of healthcare workers who are going
through one of the most dramatic plot
twists in american medical history
when the pandemic hit the nocturna's
founder dr emily silverman
started putting together an audio
library of the voices of doctors
nurses med students hospital chaplains
anyone risking their lives for covet
patients
when i get to go to sleep by all i think
about is did we do enough were we ready
enough did i help enough people
more than 700 of these recordings will
soon be on display
at the u.s library of congress it's
really been one of the most tragic
moments
i had witnessed what did you learn
from listening to some of these audio
diaries one thing that i realized is the
importance of leadership
the importance of touch and connection
not just with our loved ones at home but
in the hospital i haven't shaken hands
with a patient
in two months other themes is this idea
of
sacrifice what it means to be a
healthcare worker what it means to be of
service
the nocturna's work is part of a bigger
movement by made by
us my wish for us my wish for us my wish
for us is for our country to become the
moral beacon of the world
a nationwide collaboration with over a
hundred historical institutions and
museums
working to preserve kovitz history in
real time
this collaboration is to focus on
younger generations and to help them
to understand the importance of history
louise mirror is the ceo of the new york
historical society
which is collecting coveted related
documents photos
and artifacts in order to benefit from
history
you need to collect and preserve your
own
present moment so it sounds like what
you're saying is
how we save and how we represent history
is actually not
just about looking backwards but it's
about what we're able to then bring
collectively to our future the curious
thing about
many people's perception of history is
that history
is the dead past and that is so
completely untrue
history is about today their collection
ranges
from a baby blanket from a birth at the
height of the pandemic
to footage of a deserted new york city
and a spider-man statue that was placed
outside of a hospital
to thank frontline workers like missy
having
these collective experiences i hope will
make people
understand what it's been like for these
patients for the families
for all of us
these organizations are also collecting
items like pots and pans which i never
would have thought to collect but
that helps us remember those intangible
moments it actually reminds me of my own
two daughters running into the kitchen
to grab their pots pans and stand at the
door and cheer for healthcare workers
every night at 7 pm
such a powerful memory for me yeah me
too tara listen you were one of the
first people to start telling us about
the health care workers i'm so grateful
that a year later
unfortunately you're still telling it
but i am glad you are telling the story
thank you tara we all know the story
about banging the pots and pans and
i like this nocturne is what it means to
be a health care worker please so we
never forget thank you tara